[Music]
I'm good
you look fantastic thank you you know I
was curious because um I saw last year
you played a Cagefighting serial killer
it's an amazing role in the movie Alex
Cross let's show a still from the movie
this is how you transformed yourself for
that film yeah that's exactly what I
look like under this suit by the way
I believe don't but I was like first of
all how did you achieve that look I mean
was it just not eating anything and
working out 24/7 no I I had six months
to prepare and I wanted to go slow with
it and so and I wanted it to be very
healthy and so I had somebody who helped
me it was mainly I'd say was about 75%
diet and 25% working out really hard and
it was very structured and it was more
of a exercise and discipline for me
really but what about okay your your
family people in your life who saw you
when you had you know walking around in
a bathing suit looking like that were
they concerned for you were they really
well my daughter at one point walked up
to me and I think this was about halfway
through the process and said dad you you
look really hideous I get that all the
time and I took that as a compliment
because I knew I was headed in the right
direction I mean that was the idea that
I had for the guy and I knew I was I was
getting there my mother was absolutely
appalled by really well I think my mom's
just want you to eat right yes and
that's one of her major motivations in
life is to feed you Italian mother and
every time I would see her she would
literally gasp and and and asked if she
could feed me something right pasta
something my mother anytime I go home
she's always like you want some eggs you
want so just randomly start naming foods
then I could have a muffin corn on the
cob and I'm like I'm I'm good I'm fine
it's just this obsession she has with
everybody eating all the time